so tired of living she just wanted being
a piece grabbed a Glock that a B deed
left under the bed cocked that thing
back and put him right to the head the
last words that she said is I'm coming
home because she don't wanted to be in
this world alone now she'd gone you know
what I mean
in the 1980s and 90s a new type of
hip-hop music called gangsta rap was
becoming very popular in California
artists like NWA and Snoop Dogg are
emerging as cutting-edge rappers writing
songs about gang activity and street
violence in their own communities
often with songs and videos that seem to
larger than life something new is
happening in the Golden State
prosecutors are using those violent rap
lyrics as part of evidence in criminal
trials against would be rappers and a
lot of the time not much else my rap
name is lies the boy from Richmond
California it just was a way for me to
express myself and be able to show the
world that I can do something do
something else try to give the people
around me motivation to be able to say
we could come from nothing
I've known DeAndre about a year and a
half as long as I've been representing
him on this case John Hamasaki is a
criminal defense attorney in San
Francisco he has been a aspiring rapper
I think beyond aspiring to some degree
at this point he has achieved some local
success Mitchell was 29 when he was
arrested and charged with two counts of
attempted murder and the charges are
harsher because prosecutors say that
he's in a gang which he denies he's been
awaiting trial at the Martinez detention
facility for two years and could face
life in prison the charges came about
through a secret proceeding called a
grand jury where there is no judge no
defense attorney and no defendant
present in a grand jury the prosecution
is allowed to do pretty much what they
want the proceeding was secret so all we
have are transcripts of what happened
there wasn't any physical evidence
presented no video DNA fibers
fingerprints nothing that would directly
connect Mitchell to the crime the
prosecution's case centered around the
eyewitness account of the victim who
didn't report the first shooting to
police but did report the second
shooting in which he was sitting in a
car on the street and was shot in the
chest I told the grand jury Mitchell and
two other men were involved but more on
this later the prosecutor also
introduced three rap videos made by
Mitchell which were brought up in the
testimony of a gang detective the
prosecution would play a segment of the
video and then ask the detective to
pause the tape in the
repeat certain parts of it and some of
the parts that he stopped and repeated
were there's a reference to a cater so
tea cherlapalli is a prosecutor with the
Contra Costa County District Attorney's
Office and presented the evidence
against Mitchell cater is a slang term
for an ak-47 an assault rifle even
though an ak-47 wasn't used in the crime
and Mitchell is never implicated as the
gunman yella Polly says that the videos
showed that Mitchell had the mindset to
commit such a crime and the other
reference that he that he paused on in
one song was Merck someone is to murder
them to kill them and again you'll see
that in songs including some of the
songs what you do it for Southside
Richmond by mr. Mitchell the term Merck
is used by rappers all of the time Shara
schoo Byrne is a professor of
criminology law and society at the
University of California Irvine and is
the co-author of the paper rap on trial
that details the history and scope of
rap lyrics used in criminal proceedings
and if it's not Markets I'm gonna smoke
him I'm gonna pop a cap in him I'm going
to blaze him in one case the the
prosecution actually paused the video to
a point where mr. Mitchell was had his
hands in the shape of guns and miming
shooting a gun towards the camera so
sometimes there will be gestures
there'll be hand signs it's one piece
among many pieces or points of evidence
through that song through those songs
that tended to show gang-related
activity you can turn on any video by
gangsta rappers in the 90s and the 2000s
and you can find instances of rappers
pointing the gun that is as common as
any gangsta rap video around this has
been going on since the early 90s but
we've really seen a rise in the number
of cases where this is happening and I
think that's in part due to the stalking
among prosecutors about this tactic
there's even been a training manual that
is out there teaching prosecutors that
you can use music lyrics
ooh invadin exploit the defendants true
personality you have to find a way to
transport the jury to those dark streets
and back alleyways where the the crimes
occur and where the criminals ply their
trade Alan Jackson wrote that Manuel
kübra mentioned and although he's in
private practice now he prosecuted gang
crimes in Los Angeles during the 1990s a
prosecution can never and should never
be built solely on gang evidence and
darn sure should never be built solely
on rap lyrics but if the issue is
knowledge or intent or identity or an
understanding of gang life itself of
course gang evidence is going to be
incredibly relevant and that means
certain rap lyrics that may have been
drafted by the person become relevant so
how often is this type of thing used I
would say probably if you're talking
about trials preliminary hearings other
types of hearings at least a dozen times
probably more I would say in all of the
gang trials I've tried I've probably
introduced either social media or rap
lyrics or both or rap music or both to
the jury if you think about who's
serving in our jury system in the United
States it's typically older higher
socioeconomic status typically white
they often don't have the proper context
for understanding rap music people that
don't live the same lifestyle we live or
listen to the same music we live is
going to be ignorant to the situation so
that's given the government something to
feed off of one of the things we know
about rap music is that rappers fashion
characters write and evidence of the of
that is the fact that they often use
other names besides their own not always
but most often
so there's the andre mitchell who is the
individual who is the person but then
there's the person he created the rapper
he created last boy and what happens as
we tend to assume they're one in the
same
deandre is the family man I have two
kids and everything but when when I do
music I build my character to be lads
the boy and that's that that's just
another it's just another image if you
get around me and really understand me
see what's going on you see that it
really is just an image it's not it's
not Hawaiian there's a lot of wordplay
there's a lot of exaggeration there's a
lot of metaphor simile the goal is to
use wordplay often to invert me if you
see a movie or something and it looks so
realistic and bring goosebumps your arms
you really could feel it you know to me
and that's just how I feel that's just
hot trying to make my music feel when
you actually look at the content it's
clear that this is actually drawing on
real-life experiences involving
real-life men who have in fact who had
their lives ended due to gang violence
they don't do it to anybody else's music
just only hip-hop music they don't do it
to rock n roll they don't do it the
country reggae
kuroh headed back
but I shot a man in Reno just to watch
him
well one Johnny Cash is dead but it even
Johnny Cash were alive as far as I know
no one ever suspected him of shooting
someone in Reno if he had done that and
he was charged with that then I think it
might be a different story
I hesitate to go into the motives as to
why it's used but I think that the
effect it has on jurors on ordinary
people without exposure to hip-hop
perpetuates certain myths and
stereotypes that are portrayed by the
news media of young african-american
males being involved in criminal
activity I don't see this use of
evidence as targeting young black males
in fact the overwhelming majority of
victims of gun violence in gang-related
cases often tend to be young minorities
whether african-american or Hispanic the
cases that I happen to get tended to be
against young black males young Hispanic
males
that's who joined gangs like it or leave
it
they built America this supposed to be
the land of the free is supposed to be
freedom of speech so when I use my
freedom of speech and voicing my opinion
then y'all turn around and try to use it
against me like this is this is who I am
as a person and your mind is blinded and
then y'all try to portray the jury or
anybody else who would listen like this
is more I'm as a person I don't see that
using this evidence chills anyone's
right of expression any more than
recognizing that gang evidence of any
kind chills expression at the end of the
day yes a person has a First Amendment
right to speak but when they then commit
a crime sometimes what they say will end
up being used against them Mitchell was
facing a life sentence at this point so
a plea deal was one of his best options
on November 5 2014 he pled no contest to
a single count of assault with a firearm
he was able to leave prison that day
having already served his time yella
Polly said he couldn't comment as to why
the case didn't go to trial
but it turns out the victims testimony
was pretty flimsy all along he said he
saw Mitchell of both shootings but also
told police in an interview that what he
knew was based on street gossip
he signed a legal document in August
2014
saying I never saw Deandra Mitchell
during either of the shootings and my
statements before the grand jury about
Mitchell were just based on rumors I had
heard in Richmond prosecutors want to
secure I mean they want to secure
convictions they want to make
communities safer I don't I don't
devalue those motives but what I do say
to prosecutors is you have to go about
it the hard way sometimes and that means
you have to get the evidence you have to
get the physical evidence you have to
prove the case yeah they try to revive
him but ain't no bringing them back that
quick she even lost everything that she
cared for brain gone Dorothy felt like
the Scarecrow it's been a week and Shane
slept a wink so tired of living she just
wanted to be in peace